[Music]
recently you're a guest judge is this
correct on Project Runway yeah was this
something you really wanted to do well I
love that show and then they asked me to
do it and I thought this is amazing and
then I called everybody I knew and I was
so excited and then my lawyer told me
you're not supposed to tell anybody when
you're a judge on Project Runway oh you
told people so many people so many
people and because it's a breach of
contract the contract I'd already signed
right look at it why would you yeah yeah
yeah and so that was a little scary and
then I and then I realized there at the
show that I don't like judging people it
made me feel terrible and then because
you she's not supposed to at least was
the judge of you supposed to be a little
mean right for Michael Kors makes it so
funny he's like it looks like an Afghan
bathmat you know and I'm like you're
like ha ha ha ha and then they get to me
and I'd be like I bet you tried so hard
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay like and then also I was like wait
I don't really know fashion what what am
I doing here it just all felt so wrong
but because I was such a fan of the show
then I got on the phone and I was like I
felt so bad you know for the girl who
got a vote got voted off you're not
supposed to tell anything about what
happens you told friends if someone got
voted off
no I told to make sort of describe to
I'm probably being sued right now yeah I
can hear it happening but it was really
fun and it was an honor to be on the
show i but I don't like you know being a
judge that's I was yeah I would be
worried about hurting people's feelings
yeah I think that's the thing I'm and in
this culture you're supposed to really
you know lay it on thick then that's
what that's the stuff that people like
on those shows isn't it I guess so I
mean this is also like I'm not in the
world of this I don't Twitter and I'm
not like I'm not used to the thing of
like this piece of crap will next should
never have seen the light of day or
whatever like cuz I think you know right
most of you are used to it right like
whenever you read reviews of something
they're all terrible aren't they yeah
it's a fun thing to do is to just get
it's so anonymous the social media you
can just get on there and say I wish
that person would die I know and then
you find that it's your father and
you're mad
now you are interesting because III
heard that you're also interested in
being a judge on Celebrity Apprentice is
that true because that's even gonna be
ruling problem which is I I think that I
would have fun on those shows like I did
any of those talent shows like I didn't
really want to be a judge on Project
Runway I learned I would like to be on
Project Runway like that's sort of how I
felt but I recently got invited to
present my boss with an award at the
voice Awards which is this beautiful
organization that that honors people who
have presented a positive image of
people who substance abuse problems or
mental health issues but you know how
when you get your email I like on the
phone you know you only get like the
first part and I thought I was being
invited to appear on the voice oh you
didn't read the whole thing right and I
had a whole vision of like they probably
want me to sing or do a duet with Blake
Shelton Christina Aguilera is probably
like I literally had cuz now that I'm a
judge and project corner I think they're
just inviting me everywhere or something
like so this is get it please tell me
you didn't show up you know no but I
think I have to stop doing anything on
the side right you definitely don't want
to be on Trump show because he fires
you'll get right you mean fire me no no
you buy you know Donald Trump oh yeah
wow you're good
I just Ted you know you're really good
that's how you're gonna prepare for the
show no Donald Trump no I'm ready to go
[Laughter]